okay welcome back everyone section two
thank you frederick um okay
so picking up where we left off so we
introduced the pc algorithm as a kind of
schematic for
for learning a equivalence class of
graphs
and we said that
uh in like looking in terms of the kind
of pseudo code
you plug in some conditional
independence test and some significance
level
uh alpha in order to make your judgments
of conditional independence so what does
that look like so it's important to
emphasize that at least in the kind of
classic pc
um
the way the independence test is
formulated is that the null hypothesis
is conditional independence
and so in statistical hypothesis testing
you decide whether you reject the null
right so if i observe a test statistic
that uh say it's like the partial
correlation which we'll talk about in a
second the partial correlation is very
small
then i reject the null hypothesis of
independence and that means that i keep
the edge i fail to remove the edge
if i
don't reject the null hypothesis then
that means i'm effectively accepting the
null of conditional independence which
means i do remove the edge so what this
leads to is the fact is the conclusion
that alpha the significance threshold
is something that's going to control the
sparsity of the graph that you learn in
the end as alpha gets smaller it becomes
harder and harder to retain an edge
so you're more likely to remove an edge
and so the graph gets sparser
the alpha bigger means a denser graph
so um
and and because you're doing many many
hypothesis tests of conditional
independence
alpha by itself doesn't have a
straightforward interpretation in terms
of the type 1 error
of the tests because you're doing this
multiple tests and
and the number of tests kind of varies
as you perform the algorithm so that's
why alpha is often thought of as this
kind of tuning parameter which controls
the sparsity of the estimated graph
and as was brought up earlier there are
ways of choosing alpha
in a kind of more deliberate fashion
rather than setting alpha to some fixed
uh fixed level ahead of time
in a way that might
control something like a family-wise
error rate or a false discovery rate by
using some sort of bound over the number
of tests that you perform
and i can go back to stuff talking about
choosing alpha later on
so what statistical independence test
would you use
so that depends on the family of
distributions p of x that you're willing
to assume so if you're willing to assume
that p of x is in some nice parametric
family for example gaussian
distributions or multinomial
distributions if things are
uh uh discrete
then life is easier because there's a
lot of good
statistical tests for
independents and gaussians or
independents and a multinomial
however there's also a kind of
one thing that makes an algorithm like
pc and related constraint based methods
continuously relevant even in the age of
like
much better algorithms for certain
purposes is that you can be as
non-parametric as you want to be at
least in principle so if i plug in a
non-parametric conditional independence
test that satisfies certain properties i
make no parametric assumptions in the
course of pc itself
right everything phrased in pc is in
terms of conditional independence which
is this non-parametric concept and i can
implement it using non-parametric tests
if i sort of choose
so first consider
the case where x is gaussian
and which is a kind of common setting
in that case uh conditional independence
just corresponds to partial correlation
being zero
so partial correlation which i'm going
to denote with a row i j dot s so the
partial correlation between x i and x j
given s
um
is uh you can define
this way this is a kind of recursive
definition of partial correlation which
says that for a conditioning set of size
s i
define
uh the smaller partial correlations that
are a size one less than s and i
iterate this recursive definition until
it terminates with a conditioning set of
size one in which case it's just a
function of a bunch of pairwise partial
correlations so the correlation between
i and j is just the covariance scaled by
the variances and then i could talk
about the correlation between j and k
and i and k and that combines together
to give me the partial correlation of i
and j given k and it's a recursive
definition right so this is a common uh
there's a common
parameter of interest for conditional
independence tests and gaussian settings
and it's easy to obtain estimates of
this partial correlation coefficient
based on the empirical covariance matrix
of some data set i'm not going to go
into it but it's there's like lots of
well-developed software to do this
the nice thing about partial
correlations is that
um you can construct a level alpha
uh hypothesis test by using this kind of
old trick called the fischer z
transformation
z is a function that i can apply to a
given partial correlation
calculated from a sample of size n
that looks like this like the hyperbolic
tangent kind of
uh so if i take this transformation of
the partial correlation coefficient you
can show that under the null hypothesis
that the partial correlation is exactly
zero
that thing has a
is asymptotically centered
at the
normal unit variance
and so i can reject
for an alpha level test i can just take
that transformed uh z transform partial
correlation and reject um in the kind of
usual way for a normally distributed
test statistic so if i can calculate
this thing well then i can test this
null hypothesis for gaussian
distributions in a kind of simple and
straightforward manner
there are similar tests
for for example for multinomial discrete
data using a chi-squared test statistic
or also this g-squared test statistic
you can also for parametric families use
tests based on logistic regression
coefficients or odds ratios or whatever
you like
um non-parametric tests are much
trickier
so
what i mean by non-parametric tests is
ones that make much more minimal
distributional assumptions so they don't
assume some nice family like gaussians
or multinomials
and in particular this is mostly a live
question when you have continuous
variables right like i want to
do a non-parametric test of
conditional independence in the case
where i'm
my variables are are continuous
uh and there's different ways of doing
this one kind of well-known test is
based on
ideas from uh kernel regression
so this kci tests it's called the
kernel-based conditional independence
test
which is a kind of popular one
that uh places some smoothness and
simplicity conditions on the
distribution but that are kind of pretty
broad so like square integrable
uh
stuff
and basically just uses a test statistic
that's based off of
a
conditional centralized kernel matrix so
basically you're like doing a bunch of
kernel regressions constructing the
kernel matrix taking a test statistic
was the trace of this big matrix and
then uh you can
say what the
asymptotic distribution of this test
statistic is under the null of
conditional independence and reject in
the kind of
uh normal way and this is just like a
little bit of r code to show like a
simulation you could run yourself at
home to see how well the kci test works
um it's implemented in for example this
library called conditional independence
tests
and so i can so here i'll i generate
some data where things are non-linear i
have like quadratic terms and so forth
so my linear partial correlation
coefficient stuff will is expected to do
poorly and i can uh run the
uh
kernel-based conditional independence
test and you'll notice that if you do
this
the sample size here is a hundred and it
works fine but as soon as you have like
very large sample sizes it becomes very
computationally intensive because
estimating these kernel matrices and
multiplying them together
is
hard right i think it's and i think it's
end to the third in terms of
uh complexity so it becomes really
really slow to do these kind of
non-parametric tests if you have large
sample sizes which is often the case in
which you would want to do
uh non-parametric stuff in general
so there are other so this is like one
example of a non-parametric conditional
dependence test that's available there
are other ones
kind of recently one
that has um
one proposal that's garnered some
attention is this test based on the
generalized conditional covariance
measure so this paper by
sean peters uses a test statistic that's
basically a normalized version
of this expected conditional covariance
so you can show that under the null
hypothesis of conditional independence
this thing should be zero so this is
conditional covariance and you expect
the value of that
where the conditional covariance is
defined
as such
and so you can basically
derive a test statistic that involves
estimating a bunch of these conditional
expectations using a kind of
non-parametric regression method of your
choice for example kernel-based stuff or
or whatever
and under some
uh smoothness conditions the residuals
from that test can be used to construct
a test statistic which has
a
uh you know
asymptotic distribution under the null
that you can write down and you can
reject the test of level alpha yes
i i think i'm missing something here
because the covariance
i always think of as being a
deterministic
thing it's like a measure of
substitution so what is the expect
it it's because it's a conditional
covariance okay so it's a different
number for every x test so what's your
expectations for excess great thanks
um so
this is so these examples are just like
two
kinds of proposals about non-parametric
conditional dependence tests that are
out there they involve
using non-parametric methods for
regression basically and combining them
in some sort of clever way and there are
other ways you can do this there are
other non-parametric tests available the
thing is that they all have their pros
and cons about how restrictive they are
in terms of smoothness assumptions they
impose
uh how computationally intensive they
are
um
and and so forth and this is a kind of
ongoing area of research better
conditional independence tests
okay but so then those are the kind of
ingredients that you need to do pc so
once you have chosen a test and a way of
choosing alpha the significance
threshold you can run pc and uh and your
life is good
um so the virtues of pc as i said before
is that it has this kind of
non-parametric and
um
quality and that as i can be as
non-parametric as i want to be or as i'm
sort of statistically able to be with
non-parametric independence tests it's
relatively scalable in the sense that
applications of pc
to hundreds of variables are routine
it's like thousands of variables are
like a little harder but totally
possible
uh millions are probably out of reach
for pc but you know it gets used in for
example
genetics applications um and and
then that's kind of nice
there's lots of work on improvements of
the classic pc
uh especially ones that address some of
the kind of finite sample stability
issues and the order dependence of the
tests
um
and so if you look dive into this
literature and look at pc stable for
example
or um
kernel based pc or some of these other
variations
there's been you know a 30-year history
of people doing variations on pc
the drawbacks are that
because it does a sequence of
conditional dependence tests
and future tests are in part determined
by the outcomes of previous tests
that errors propagate very poorly
so if i make a mistake if i falsely
remove an edge early on in the procedure
that limits what kinds of hypotheses i
can test later
and that can make a big difference to
the output which can to some extent be
mitigated by some of these variations
but
is fundamentally our issue
it does not handle conflicting
statistical information in a very
intelligent way
every implementation of pc
has to make some decisions about what to
do if
statistical conflicts emerge you know if
like two conditional dependence tests
which are mutually incompatible uh are
both accepted for example
um so different heuristics are are are
used for that kind of thing
so be careful about that it's not that
scalable
it's hard to
parallelize as opposed to some other
measures other algorithms which are
easier to parallelize
it tackles each problem only locally so
it's only looking at conditional
independence between
x i x j and some conditioning set
kind of individually of each other
rather than thinking about like the
global fit of the whole dag
and
and it only produces one estimated graph
which represents an equivalence class
rather than uh so what you might desire
in some settings which is like a range
of good options
so
an alternative approach is to do score
based selection for dags
as i said before score based procedures
view structure learning as an
optimization problem
basically they assign a score or a
measure of fit to every possible
structure in the class of structures and
find the one with the highest score
that's the question over there
global
comment on other versions of pc where
you first cluster
variables up in say like three groups
you learn the conditions
um the question is is there are other
versions of pc that sort of
uh cluster or sets of variables into
groups learn things locally and try to
combine them later
not exactly so there are versions of
algorithms that do something like that
in the setting where there are
unmeasured variables so where the
different clusters
may partially overlap
but not entirely overlapped
and there may be unmeasured confounders
which affect
different elements of different clusters
and so forth there is a kind of
literature on
on combining local
subgraphs into like a
new media graph
um but not quite with pc i like
[Music]
canon yeah so you'll also do the alert
just to repeat for people zoom you can
also learn first from undirected graph
using whatever like lasso graphical
lasso kind of thing and that also kind
of can help with the stability
um
uh so what kind of score might you
consider for a score based approach
a natural score uh from the bayesian
perspective is the posterior probability
of a particular structure given the data
and there's a long history of kind of
uh
not that score based learning has to
have a kind of bayesian flavor to it but
there's a long history of incorporating
busy ideas
into structure learning through this
kind of score based paradigm
the idea being that you know a more
a posteriori probable structure
is one that sort of fits the data better
and you could imagine searching for the
structure which has the highest
posterior
so how would you define this in the
space of graphs
so thinking about the bayesian network
model
the set of distributions that factorizes
according to a graph
as you know a combination of a graph and
a set of distributions that factorize
um you can sort of rephrase this as a
parametrized bayesian network model
where you just have free parameters
theta g that depend on what the graph
is
uh so these are parameters that index
distributions in the set of densities
that factorize with respect to the graph
and you can define the posterior
probability of a structure g given data
d
by using bayes rule which will
incorporate a prior probability over
graphs
the probability of each graph a priori
and something that looks like the
marginal likelihood the probability
of the data given a particular graph
which itself is
actually something that's like a kind of
average over a prior distribution over
the parameters right so there's actually
kind of two priors at play in this
version of
of a bayesian model selection there's a
prior over graphs p of g
and a prior over the parameters of a
given graph
and that's used to calculate the
likelihood or the marginal likelihood
and then there's this denominator which
is the probability of d which is going
to be the same for every graph and you
can kind of ignore for the purposes of
graph selection
so
so you can follow this kind of reasoning
and define a score
which is a function from
data and
graph to
a number which takes a candidate graph
and a data set and returns a number
proportional to the posterior
distribution so just ignoring that
denominator this would be the bayesian
score so it's like the log of the
posterior probability
ignoring the denominator there
um you can even assume that every
dag in this if you're doing this over
the space of dags you can sort of assume
that every
uh dag in the space of graphs has equal
prior probability so this number is the
same for every graph and kind of ignore
that to make it easy as a common thing
to do but it's still even if you make
that kind of simplifying
uh prior assumption that still leaves us
with trying to evaluate this marginal
likelihood so it still involves for each
particular graph some sort of prior
distribution
of the parameters
and this is pretty difficult to
calculate outside of special cases
so there's like a
a long history of work in especially in
the early 90s about how to
evaluate the marginal likelihood for
special classes
of graphs and distributions for example
dags with
binary variables or gaussian variables
which kind of depends on
choosing a conjugate prior for the
probability of theta given g
in a way such that the marginal
likelihood is kind of easy to calculate
do that integral so as an example if you
choose a prior that's a dirschlag over
theta
then
you can show that the marginal
likelihood has a kind of
uh easy form and there's a few other
convenient choices like this but in
general
that's a hard thing to do
and hard to adapt to kind of different
circumstances so i think it's much more
common to instead use an approximation
to the marginal likelihood that doesn't
require specifying a whole bunch of
prior stuff
uh in particular using the bic score the
bayesian information criteria
so
for distributions in the exponential
family the bic score is an approximation
to the marginal likelihood
under some very weak assumptions about
the prior
in particular you can show that the log
of the marginal likelihood
is approximately like the
uh
log likelihood of the data where i plug
in the mle estimate for theta
minus a complexity penalty where d is
the dimension of the graph the number of
free parameters that you have to
estimate and log n is log of the sample
size plus something that's one
so so that means that i can effectively
approximate this uh marginal likelihood
by doing maximum likelihood for whatever
parametric family i'm working in
plugging in the mle and then penalizing
it in an appropriate way and that
asymptotically that's the same as
maximizing the marginal likelihood
so uh this is a kind of
and so
asymptotically maximizing the marginal
likelihood is kind of the same as
asymptotically maximizing the posterior
probability if i assume an equal prior
over all possible graphs and so then
people just use that thing itself as the
score so basically saying the score is
the likelihood evaluated at the mle
minus this penalty
yeah
like the number of individual graphs
that i can consider can be exponential
yeah so the question is how should how
should one think of the space of
possible graphs that you're willing to
consider
so
i think it's worth separating like the
space of possible graphs that you're
willing to consider as like possible you
know hypothesis class to sort of put it
in the machinery way
versus how you might traverse that space
like search over that space so the space
of possible graphs might be
uh in this setting like the space of
dags or the space of cp dags the
equivalence files of that so for every
cp tag i want to be able to assign it a
score and i'm searching over the space
of cp
and then how to traverse that space is
what we're going to get to next which is
usually using a greedy algorithm that
doesn't require that we actually list
all i mean obviously the brute force
approach would be list all the possible
cp dags over p variables which is just
kind of impossible to do so instead
we're going to do a kind of reading
approach to the space
here
is i guess from amazing perspective kind
of assuming a uniform prior over
graphical structures and some sort of
smooth prior over parameters and then
maximizing the bic score is kind of like
doing
uh maximum a posteriori entrance right
that's the bayesian interpretation
alternatively you can do this without
thinking about posteriors and just
thinking of the bic score as some
measure of model fit which is a kind of
penalized maximum likelihood estimate
and
so the second term penalizes the maximum
likelihood question in a way that's uh
proportional to the complexity but that
decays with n as log n
so uh
why do you want to do this so if i
didn't penalize it at all i could just
imagine picking graphs based on their
mle estimates of the parameters but this
will lead me to overfit i can always get
a better likelihood by just including
more parameters basically including a
more dense
graph
and letting those parameters be like
close to zero things are close to
vanishing and so if i didn't penalize
this
likelihood in some way i'm going to
always fit a too dense graph so i won't
have consistency if the truth is
potentially sparse
so you need some sort of
simplicity penalty
um
but uh which penalty in particular
comes from these kind of asymptotic
arguments about consistency
so this particular sparsity penalty of
bic
is proportional to d thing
um
you can show there's like papers by
schwartz and then paper by houghton in
1988 that for at least for exponential
families makes the score consistent so
asymptotically you're you're going to
select the true model regardless of the
true complexity
and other penalties you might come up
with do not come with that guaranteed in
particular the aic criterion which
gives you a penalty that's independent
of n is not you know it might be
useful for other purposes like selecting
a model with good predictive
qualities or whatever but it's not going
to be consistent uh it's not
asymptotically going to select the best
model
so
uh
so the i guess
the kind of hand-wavy answer is that if
you read
the paper by hotten from 1988 you see
that like changes to this complexity
term
that don't let it decay appropriately
with sample size
will ruin kind of consistency guarantees
you can multiply this penalty term by
any fixed constant greater than zero and
still get consistency though so that
part
is kind of free this was a question
there yeah so is d the number of
parameters with respect to a fixed graph
g so what if that's the case why do you
say that d controls the sparsity of the
graph
it's sort of uh for
um
for different candidate graphs it's
going to
penalize the likelihood more or less
right so if i if i compare two graphs
one that has
more edges and some more parameters to
estimate it's going to give you a larger
penalty
a larger sort of subtraction term
compared to the
the likelihood term as compared to a
more sparse graph that has a smaller d
like the likelihood those two graphs
might have the same likelihood
approximately the sparse graph and the
dense graph but the dense graph will
have a lower score because it's
penalized more
that make sense
should there be a parameter that
controls the weight of the complex model
penalty
um so that we can manually select more
complex or simple models why would that
happen here
so this is again
yeah so
could you that's kind of what i was just
trying to say is that
the
asymptotic consistency argument holds
for any you can add like a lambda which
is a positive coefficient in front of d
over log n and then you still get the
same asymptotic behavior but this is the
kind of form
that you get from the original vic score
as an approximation to the marginal
weight
so d is
the number of parameters in the graph
which for simple graph classes is
basically the number of edges yes so it
depends if you so
uh like say you're thinking about a
linear model
then it's like every edge has a
parameter
and but then maybe it's two because you
have variances for each model unless you
standardize the variances
so i'm leaving it kind of open for here
but it's whatever
the dimension is
so how is it different from this um p of
g that you totally just removed
the p of g
yes yes
so p of g is a prior over every possible
graph in the space so sam is in some
space
of
bold face g
and each
script g is some graph in that space so
if i assume that they're all the same
then it's just a constant
so i'm not incorporating any
prior pmg when i do the vic score thing
but in order to interpret it as a
maximization of the posterior you have
to assume that this thing is a constant
otherwise i'd have to find a different
score for every
i'd have to sort of weight the score by
the prior graph prior on over graphs as
well but you could do you could
you could use a version of this vxc
score that also had a term
that penalized a priori unlikely graphs
more
and uploaded a priority likely graphs
uh differentially but here it doesn't
doesn't incorporate any file over graphs
right
but the d log n is kind of already
penalizing certain graphs right
it's penalizing graphs just based on the
complexity but like i could have
multiple graphs in the same complexity
that were sort of treated the same here
whereas if i recorded it versus prior
they can be have different kind of
problems
particular
choice of graph like say i have
this graph here as my candidate g
then i'll have like
a bunch of a bunch of parameters and
maybe the maybe like variance of x one
is
theta two is theta three
variance of x
two is
negative four
and so on so theta is the collection of
parameters that parameterizes a given
graph
which for linear models is like edge
coefficients and variances
or for
uh multinomial models is the cell
probability
so it's specified
another quick question
is there an intuitive
explanation for that
uh the explanation for the log n is that
the asymptotic arguments for
for
how much the complexity should trump
likelihood comparisons has to decay
fast enough so you you show so in the
pit
i have to go back to the paper but in
hotman's paper from 88 you can show that
the differences between likelihoods for
kind of neighboring graphs
is
going to be
uh
similar to log n so you have to have
something that indicated at this rate in
order to like outweigh the differences
between likelihood
um
okay so as an example for a particular
parametric family that's very common is
the
multivariate gaussian so in that case
the score just ends up being like
the
maximum likelihood
estimate of the covariance matrix which
i'll call sigma hat here minus this
penalty so i can compare for every
candidate graph i can just derive what
the mle is for that graph for gaussian
gaussian data
estimate it and then penalize it
appropriately
so if computational limitations weren't
an issue if i really could just like
list all the possible graphs
i might do something
uh similar to what we saw before like
list every possible graph in the space
that i'm interested in
calculate the score for each one and
pick the graph with the highest score
i'll notice that some graphs will have
the same score because if they imply for
example if they imply the same
conditional dependence constraints then
they're all going to apply imply the
same
uh covariance matrix in the case of
gaussian graphs right because the
covariance matrix just just really
capturing conditional dependencies in
the first place so they'll have the same
likelihood
and they'll have the same complexity
because we know that markov equivalent
graphs have the same number of edges so
they'll have the same number of free
parameters
so it'll have the same likelihood same
complexity means i'll have the same
score
and so
uh
so
this is a procedure that i can sort of
imagine but i can't actually carry out
and wouldn't be the most efficient thing
to carry out so instead
the kind of standard approach is to use
a greedy score based algorithm that does
stepwise optimization of this bic score
in a way that i don't have to traverse
the whole space of graphical structures
but just have to make local moves
between neighboring graphs in a way that
is still ideally globally optimal so
provably we'll find the optimal scoring
graph and the limit as n goes to
infinity
and that's what the greedy equivalence
search algorithm does
and it's operating in the space of cp
dags
equivalence classes of graphs
so as a kind of schematic of how that
works
to kind of parallel what we did with pc
imagine just like four variables
so pc started off with a complete graph
right and started removing edges
ges instead has a forward stage and a
backward stage where the forward stage
starts off into the empty graph
it adds edges one at a time to improve
the score until it can no longer improve
the score by any single edge additions
and then it starts removing edges one at
a time to improve the score
more
so it'll start off with this empty graph
over four variables it'll ask which
single edge so like the four variables i
can add any one of these edges right so
there's a bunch of edges i could add
it'll score each possible edge addition
and pick the one that has the
highest improvement in score so it makes
it greedy
so it'll add the edge which improves the
score the most add the next edge which
given this previous one improves the
score the most
and so forth and keep adding edges to
improve the score
until it achieves a kind of local
optimum where it can no longer improve
the score by adding single edges anymore
and then it'll start removing edges to
try and additionally improve the score
and
and then
the kind of another
trick that makes it possible to um
to think of this as consistent in the
space of cp dags is that in every step
it kind of keeps track of markov
equivalents so using a few graphical
rules it'll say
well i'm kind of it only really
considers adding and removing directed
edges actually at every step but it sort
of says well
what are the unshielded colliders in
this graph that i just created and
everything else should be unoriented
because only the unshielded colliders
and the graph i created really have an
orientation and so it kind of keeps
track and unorients edges whenever
they're not unshielded colliders
so uh the pseudo code for ges is like a
little harder to parse but it's um
let's give it a try i guess so
so the overall procedure has a forward
search and a backwards search so it
starts off with an empty graph
it defines some sort of score like the
bic score
um
it does this forward search and then it
starts from the
result of the forward search and does a
backward search so the forward search
looks like
this kind of thing
um
where basically
you initialize a bunch of empty lists
and then you set you look at every
candidate edge between i and j where
they're not already adjacent
and uh you
calculate how much so from the empty
score
uh how much that added edge improves the
score with a sub routine here is called
score edge addition
and so you sort of keep a list of how
much each thing improves the score
and then you keep it if it improves the
score more than any of the other ones in
the list
and then you have a step at the end
which
looks at some unoriented edges
and keeps track of markov equivalents
but basically just looking at colliders
and the backward stage is just the
backwards version of this it starts off
with some graph that you've just learned
from the forward stage
and then it iterates through adjacencies
and sees how much removing that edge
improves the score and keeps the one
that improves the score the most
and then keeps track of
uh
unoriented edges for markup equivalents
so each sort of subroutine here is like
doing
a little bit of work so you have to
decide
whether inserting an edge or removing an
edge is a valid operation based on
respecting the markov equivalence
properties of the graph so you can just
kind of they're like graphical results
based on
what's undirected and what's adjacent to
what basically
to determine whether every particular
edge addition or removal is valid
uh the score edge addition and score
edge deletion i'm leaving out here but
it's just calculating differences
between
score of g prime versus g
um and then rebuild this step at the end
uh is the one that sort of unorients
um unorientable edges basically
unorients everything that's not an
unshielded collider and then propagates
those same rules r1 through r4 that we
talked about earlier in pc to orient
some stuff that's acyclic so i didn't
include all the subroutines here this
paper
uh so the kind of
details of the procedure and the proof
of its um correctness is in this paper
by
uh chickering from 2002 um
actually this particular formulation of
the pseudocode i was following a paper
by
ramsey at all from 2010 in their
appendix they have it written out nicely
so but that's basically the whole
procedure it involves a forward search a
backwards search at each stage it
calculates
how much the score changes whether it's
valid and then keeps track of more
coverage
yes question from zoom do gesi and uh
always end up with the same graph
um the question is did gs and kc end up
with the same graph so asymptotically
since they're both correct
and consistent procedures yes they
should end up with the same graph in
practice
almost certainly not because
uh data is hard so like as as
although
although
the procedures are asymptotically kind
of equivalent in the sense of returning
the same cp tag
as we said earlier for pc
when pc makes a mistake it makes a
mistake about a conditional independence
test which then affects future
conditional dependence tests
and ges makes a mistake it makes it like
falsely adds or falsely removes an edge
right
um but a nice thing about ges is it's
like a little bit more robust to
mistakes than pc because it kind of has
two chances right if it falsely added an
edge it'll probably remove it in the
backwards stage
so
that's the kind of
reason why in a lot of
these small sample settings
ges will perform somewhat better than
vanilla pc
uh because it has this kind of
second chance to recover from a mistake
yes
you say that you've got a global optimum
that's the case when in the limit of
infinite data
this translate to any optimality
guarantees with finite data
um
so
so the question is about optimality
guarantees of finite data so
similar to
pc you can prove a kind of uniform
consistency result for gds which i'll
mention again to the end of this
presentation
which gives you like an error bound
for being
uh incorrect about what the ultimate
graph is
um
so i guess in that sense and so it's a
financial guarantee but it's not one
that's really like actable on because
it's really a limit result that just
tells you the rate at which it
approaches the truth but it's not going
to give you
uh you know like a pac bound or like a
here's a sample size n at which i know
i'm
excellent away from the global optimum
or something like that
so yes um are there
are there results for ges or
or algorithms like gs that are scored
based
it's a
um
we have like a constant factor of uh
crocs approximation maybe on some
functions of the underlying distribution
um
results about constant factor
approximation to do this
no not really as the way that you're
saying it as far as i know i mean there
i think the results that
there's like
uh i think i have this here
like the results
are kind of similar to pc in the sense
that there's like an oracle result that
it tells you with correct
as the correct improvements in the score
and stuff
and guaranteed to get the right thing
and then there's like asymptotic results
that tell you that i converge to the
truth of sample size increases
but there's not really anything that
tells you how far away you are from the
true graph uh in that way exactly as far
as i know
but let me say let me summarize a little
bit about like similar to what we did
with pc the logic of ges
is that um the highest like we've
defined a score such that the highest
scoring model will in the limit as n
goes to infinity be a member of the true
equivalence class or representation of
the true equivalence class
we're adding and removing edges
incrementally to improve the score and
and we're doing this in a way that is
surprisingly i'm going to get to this in
a second but surprisingly we'll achieve
a global optimum it's generally greedy
stepwise things and statistics are not
typically consistent like stepwise
regression
not typically consistent in
in settings that we care about but sort
of like the cleverness of ges in the way
that it makes its moves is that you can
prove that it will land on the global
optimum at least as as n goes to
infinity and i'll get to that in a
second
and then the last sort of logic bit is
keeping track of markov equivalence uh
to and and using the same rules
so uh let me say a bit more about the
score properties
so uh to to make greedy search for cp
dags globally
optimal
the score we use should satisfy these
three abstract properties and it turns
out the bic score at least for
exponential families
does provably satisfy these three
abstract properties
the three properties are consistency
score equivalence and decomposability
so consistency is that the true
structure will maximize the score
so that for all graphs that are not the
true one the score for the true one
should be higher than the rest
and so that's a property you can sort of
see kind of from bic because it's
it's like bayesian consistency it's like
it's approximation to the posterior the
posterior is highest for the truth and
so
uh bic sort of inherits this kind of
thing
uh score equivalence is also important
so that it scores equally
markov equivalent graphs
this is sort of
uh natural like kind of satisfied for
free for
um certain families of distributions
like gaussians
um but you can also define scores that
violate this for certain classes of
distributions so this is why it's sort
of important to think about the
exponential family or some family in
which you're kind of
guaranteed to have the score equivalence
property and then finally
decomposability
which says that i can decompose the
score of an entire graph
into a sum of scores of local pieces of
the graph so we know the joint
distribution factorizes as the product
of every
variable given its parents and so the
score for the graph should basically
factorize like the probability or the
score of every variable given its
parents so that's what and this is true
again for the bic score
so these three properties
uh
uh are
kind of
key to proving the consistency or global
optimality of
ges they imply this
uh further property that's kind of
uh
worth examining a little bit it's key to
the proof
um
it's called local consistency which is
the following property it says that if g
is any dag
and g prime is a dag that results from
adding an additional edge between i and
j
then the scoring
criterion is called locally consistent
if whenever ing are
not independent
given the parents of j
then the score for the
added one
should be bigger than the score for the
uh one where that edge is absent right
so like basically adding the edge should
improve the score of probability one
whereas if they're actually independent
so they're d separated then i shouldn't
have improved the score i should have
decreased it that's a kind of local
consistency
so um
this is a kind of nice
property because it means that single
edge score differences the differences
between graphs that just differ by one
edge actually have this kind of
correspondence to a conditional
independence test
so i alluded to this earlier when i said
that score based methods and constraint
based methods
are not that different in a sense
because they're
they're both testing conditional
independence constraints
but constraint based methods are looking
at conditional dependence constraints
with hypothesis tests whereas score
based methods are looking at score
comparisons to basically check
conditional dependence constraints
and so that leads this kind of result
that um at least for gaussian
distributions it kind of looks works out
nicely that if i compare two graphs like
that that differ by one edge that their
score difference is just a function of
their partial correlation for that
adding that edge
so it's just like
rho is the partial correlation so just
like a measure of how dependent i and j
are given the parents and so it's just
the score difference just ends up being
this it's like a test statistic that's
like related to the partial correlation
and since ges only looks at score
differences
um this is actually kind of nice because
it lets you
it leads to some strategies for doing
something kind of more semi or
non-parametric for ges part of the issue
of ges is that you're calculating
likelihoods to calculate a score and
that's easy to do for
gaussian data or multinomial data but
non-parametrically you kind of want to
avoid calculating entire likelihoods but
the nice thing about
the score differences formulation is
that the score differences kind of
really just capture a conditional
independence fact so if you have a
non-parametric
measure of that conditional independence
strength it kind of you can use it in
place of score differences in a certain
way and this has been used in some
recent papers this one's uh by billy
wang
that defines a kind of generalized score
metric using kernel regression
and leads to a kind of more
non-parametric formulation of ges
so so these results these properties
lead to this kind of
these kind of theoretical guarantees
that
because the bic score satisfies
these three properties it also satisfies
local consistency and that means that
i can i can show that assuming the
distribution is markov and faithful to a
dag then i'll learn the correct cp dag
um
in the limit of infinite sample size
and as a kind of well i don't know if
it's time for this actually um
i'm going to skip this so
so the virtues and drawbacks of score
based search
are
that
it's easy to parallelize because you are
kind of only looking at score based
single edge differences and in like one
part of the graph and so you kind of
don't care what's happening in another
part of the graph so you can do these at
the same time so there are parallel
implementations of ges which are
super scalable
um
it's less prone to statistical errors
than constraint based search because of
this like ability to
uh to
recover from some mistakes
um the drawbacks are that at least in
the sort of classic formulation you need
to specify likelihood so it's not kind
of as straightforward to do
non-parametrically as as pc might be
um the results all these results about
bic score are restricted to exponential
families for example
although there is this kind of
active area of non-parametric scores
there's no
uh people like it because they think
they don't need to choose a tuning
parameter alpha
i think this is kind of a
false sense of comfort because you can
sort of choose a family of scores that
are all asymptotically equivalent but
are different for finite sample size as
we said earlier you can multiply the
complexity penalty by alpha and it'll be
a consistent score so it's kind of nice
because in the software people don't
think about that a lot of time but
in in reality there's also a free
parameter there
um
and then another drawback is that this
might not really be true anymore but
it's like kind of harder to prove stuff
about greedy search
than
pc um because it's sort of more
graphical what you're doing at every
step uh so
so but there are results for ges that
parallel pc
so one of those so what are those kind
of stronger results that people keep
asking about look like
so there's a kind of series of papers
that deals with
um
uniform consistency results specifically
in high dimensional settings where not
only n is growing to infinity sample
size but also p is growing
to infinity but in a way such that p is
uh much much greater than n
so
this uh as always in statistics you're
going to make
you want if you want stronger guarantees
about rates of convergence and things
like that you're going to need to make
stronger assumptions
so the sum at least one version of the
assumptions is usually formulated like
this
um
so a1 is the assumption so because now
i'm letting the graph grow as n goes to
infinity that means the graph is sort of
indexed by n and the distribution is
also indexed by n
uh question there so just to be sure uh
what is the
identity of which variable n is the side
the graph
and it's the sample size
lowercase p is the number of vertices
okay but p grows with n
and each one each graph induces some
distribution that i'm calling p of nx
so what's the logic beyond this kind of
making graph escapes within
uh what's the logic behind making a
graph scale again
um i'm not the best person to answer
that question because i
but it's like in high dimensional
statistics the idea is that
you want guarantees like a guarantee for
n greater than p
when you have p into the order of many
thousands
and a actual sample size with like a
hundred it's kind of misleading right
because you're just sort of saying that
eventually my data swamps my i'm no
longer high dimensional eventually my
data swamps my dimension but they want
to keep that the dimension kind of grows
with the data so that i'm high
dimensional at every sample size
but you can uh
you can
replace what i i'm about to say with a
fixed p so that'll just change
assumption two and everything else just
makes p fixed and the same stuff
um so the first assumption is i'm going
to assume that the distribution is
gaussian although that part is actually
not essential um as long as the tests
kind of work out in the right way
asymptotically consistently i'm going to
assume it's also faithful to some dag g
for all sample size
yes
when you say we get hey i'm going again
back to your regimentation you say i can
fix
a
alpha equals zero and having a constant
size of graph
i didn't say you're fixing alpha yet i
just said
i this is a result that's
the results on the next slide but it's
going to let n go to infinity and p goes
to infinity
yeah that would be the classical results
so in this case i'm going to allow the
dimension grows with n but like
polynomial
in the size of the sample
um i'm going to require that there's a
fixed
uh or not fixed but there's a maximum
number of neighbors in the graph
uh gn
that so this is like qn is the
maximal size of the adjacency set for
any
vertex
uh and i'm allowing it to grow with n
but also polynomial
and then the last assumption is
uh
that the partial correlations or if
you're doing a kind of non-gasoline
version of this whatever measure of
dependence you're interested in testing
should be bounded from below and above
so all non-zero partial correlations
have to be
c n away from zero
so that means you can't have stuff
that's arbitrarily close to zero
and partial correlations have to be
bounded away from one and that's just
actually that part is common to pretty
much all conditional dependence tests
but this part this like bounding partial
correlations away from zero that's a
strong assumption right so then so
together this in femur over partial
correlations with the faithfulness
assumption is sometimes called strong
faithfulness because it's sort of ruling
out
almost unfaithful distributions so you
can't be arbitrarily close to unfaithful
if you make this assumption
and under under that set of assumptions
uh just thinking about pc
with the fischer z test of conditional
independence do you get the following
kind of results
um if c hat is the output of pc
then there is a sequence of alphas so
alpha is going to have to shrink to zero
with sample size
such that the probability of
of uh being correct
is
uh going to one and this is the root for
some choice of constant c
um
in particular you can show that if you
choose the alpha rate to shrink at this
particular
at this particular rate which depends on
the sample size and that minimum partial
correlation size
then you can calculate you can show that
this this uh
this equality holds and you can
calculate a kind of loose bound
on the error on the probability that c
hat is not equal to c
and similar results exist for
a wider range of distributions
especially kind of the semi-parametric
families or gaussian copulas that kind
of use a general
version of partial correlation to do
their tests
so as sort of as long as you have a
statistical test that satisfies certain
properties you can get this kind of
result for pc
um
i can give you like a really rough
sketch of how the proof
looks for this kind of thing this is not
an actual proof but sort of what the
ingredients are
so the ingredients are
first like if you think about
so when i do pc i'm doing a bunch of
conditional independence tests with
larger and larger cardinality of the
conditioning set so let m be the maximum
size of that conditioning set like m is
the largest number of variables i have
to condition on in the course of pc and
let that vary with n
then then i'm sort of i'm actually going
to analyze a version of the algorithm
that's called like pc indexed with a
maximum sample maximum conditioning set
size mn
and then later make a separate argument
that that's going to converge to the
regular pc
um let e i j give an s to note the event
that an error occurs when testing a
particular
conditional independence hypothesis so
that row i j given s is equal to zero
then the probability of an error
occurring in pc
is
uh bounded by the probability of any
error occurring for any test and then
the union bound says that that's
something that looks like um o
p to the m uh so it's like i'm bounding
the number of tests that i have to
perform and then i have the worst case
probability of any test being wrong
and then it kind of appeals to a couple
of results about the consistency
properties of conditional independence
tests namely that there's two ways that
a test can go wrong you can have a type
one error or a type two error
and
some some math leads you to the
conclusion that for any ijs
the supremum of the probability of an
error occurring for
of each kind can be bounded
by
an expression that looks like this for
some choice of constants
and those bounds together
lead you to the probability that an
error occurs at all is bounded by this
thing
which uh
so something that looks like the number
of tests that you do and this
exponential thing and depends on the
minimum partial correlation size
and um
because we assumed that p grows with n
like a polynomial n to a you get
something that looks like this and some
other constants around and so that's the
sort of like high level sketch of what
you need to establish
to prove this kind of consistency result
is like a bound on the
you know something that looks like the
bound on the number of tests and the
probability of an error a bound on each
of the kind of errors that you can make
and then combine in those ways and then
there's a final step that i ignore here
but that proving that pc
sub m
uh eventually goes to the truth as n
goes to infinity as well
so that's how the proof goes
so um i'll conclude by saying that so
the previous results that i was just
presenting is as formulated in this
paper by kalish and bulemen
um
the combination of faithfulness and the
lower bound on partial correlations a4
is called strong faithfulness and has
been criticized
uh or identified as a strong assumption
uh by caroline in the back and her
co-authors in this in a kind of precise
sense that
those kind of measure zero arguments
that people like to make about
regular faithfulness don't quite carry
over when you start talking about almost
unfaithfulness so you can show that it's
kind of the violations of strong
faithfulness or dense
in a measure theoretic sense
uh similar results with somewhat
stronger assumptions have improved for
ges but it's basically the same kind of
thing
um
and that there's uh approach so because
of this
the strength of this
strong faithfulness assumption there's
an interest in
weakening strong faithfulness but in a
way that still gets you
uniform consistency and so there's some
work that uses a kind of intermediate
assumption that's stronger than regular
faithfulness but weaker than strong
faithfulness that's called k triangle
faithfulness and so you can prove a
uniform consistent consistency result
for a kind of modified pc
uh under that intermediate assumption
so i'll conclude here since it's noon
and then after lunch we're going to talk
about uh unmeasured variables latent
variables and confounding and how things
work in that domain
[Music]
these methods have been assigned to
or that we would like to apply this to
do they seem to work well are they used
as part of the larger pipeline are they
domains where we don't expect them to
work so well
maybe you want to take the data
yeah that's a complicated multi-part
question i guess i mean i'd say very
briefly the domains in which
um
procedures or versions of them have been
applied
so far in ways that are promising at
least are usually in genetics or
neuroscience so high dimensional
settings where you have a large number
of variables whether those are gene
expressions
or
regions of interest in the brain and
maybe some other parts of computational
biology like protein level
uh stuff
uh but in terms of whether we want them
to be applied
uh you know the sky's the limit
okay i can talk more about applications
later on
also just another brief question is
what's the relationship between
minimality faithfulness and something
like cruciality
um
uh
i
don't know if i remember the formal
results off the top of my head but i'm
pretty sure markov
doesn't mark out the plus
so minimality is weaker than
faithfulness by itself
i don't remember there's like some
relationship that maybe other people
remember about how you can um stronger
from a combination of weaker things but
um
like yesterday you're on your own for
your lunch i just want to say one other
thing uh about tomorrow so that you can
think about how you're going to handle
it for tomorrow already tomorrow the day
is going to be streamed online thomas is
going to not be here in person we'll
have the screen here with the
presentation i will certainly be here
you can log on to
the stream from home if that's what you
would prefer
i of course would like to see you here i
think it's not the coffee will be there
the bricks will be there the chats will
be there in the in between but the
actual lecture will be all online
tomorrow okay but the room will be open
we'll run it here i'll say this again at
the end of the second section
maybe you want to talk to each other